PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Did you know that most
of the time spent
by data scientists
goes into wrangling data?
More specifically, in
feature engineering,
which is transforming raw
data into high-quality input
signals for ML models.
But this process is often
inefficient and brittle.
Well I'm Priyanka,
and in this video
we will identify
the key challenges
with feature engineering, how
Vertex Feature Store help solve
them, and see a quick demo.
Now what are the key
challenges with ML features?
The first is that they are
hard to share and reuse
across your different
steps of the ML workflow
and across projects, which
results in duplicate efforts.
Second is that it is hard to
serve in production reliably
with lower latency,
and the third
is that there is an
inadvertent skew in feature
values between
training and serving,
usually, which causes your model
quality to degrade over time.
That is exactly where Vertex
Feature Store comes in.
It's a fully managed
and unified solution
to share, discover,
and serve machine
learning features at scale
across different teams
within your organization.
And it also helps
reduce the time
to build and deploy
your AI ML applications
by making it easy to
manage and organize
your ML features in one place.
It makes the features reusable,
easy to serve, and avoids skew.
Now let's see how to set it up.
In the console, in Vertex
AI, we see the Feature tab.
To get started, let's
click on this documentation
and explore, using
Feature Store section.
Now the first thing you
need is a Feature Store.
At the time of this
recording, Feature Store
is in preview so just
know that depending
on when you're watching this,
there might be more options
and updates that you would see.
You cannot create a Feature
Store in the console,
so let's use this sample
notebook to learn how to create
it using the SDK.
This sample uses a movie
recommendations data
set and the task
is to train a model
to predict if a user is
going to watch a movie
and serve this model online.
We will learn to import our
features into Feature Store,
serve online prediction requests
using the imported features,
and then access imported
features in offline jobs,
such as training jobs.
To set up, we install
some additional packages,
set up our project, and
authenticate our Google Cloud
account.
Step one is to create
data set for output.
We are creating BigQuery data
set to host the output data.
Input the name of the
data set and the table
we want to store
the output later.
Then we are defining
constants and
Feature Store-related imports.
Here's how the Vertex
Feature Store actually works.
It organizes the data with the
three hierarchical concepts.
Featurestore, which is the
place to store your features--
EntityType, under Featurestore,
describes an object
to be modeled, real or
virtual, and Feature itself,
under EntityType, describes an
attribute of that EntityType.
Now in our movie's
prediction example,
we will create a featurestore
called movie_prediction.
This store has
two entity types--
Users and Movies.
The user's entity
type has age, gender,
and like genres features.
The Movies entity type has
the genre and average rating
features.
The first thing we do is
to create the featurestore.
The method to create
a featurestore
returns a long
running operation that
starts an asynchronous job.
This may take about
three minutes or so,
and once the
featurestore is created,
we can see it in the console.
And we can create our
entities in this store.
I'm creating two entities here--
user and movies.
We can also create features
within these entities.
Here I've created age,
gender, and like genres
under user, and title,
genres, and average rating
under our movies.
If we want, we
can search through
and filter on these features.
Now we need to import feature
values before we can use them
for online offline serving.
Let's head back
into our notebook
to see how to import features
in bulk using the Python SDK.
We define the data source, the
BigQuery table or Cloud Storage
bucket, and the destination
featurestore, entity
and the features to be imported.
You do this for both users
and the movies entities.
Now for a latency-sensitive
service such as online model
prediction, we would need
to serve our feature values
online.
For example, for
a movie service,
we might want to
quickly show movies
that the current user
would most likely watch
by using online predictions.
You can read one
entity per request
or even read multiple
entities per request.
Now if you need feature
values for high throughput,
typically for training a
model or batch prediction,
then serving feature
values in batch
is a better idea
than serving online.
Consider this example-- if the
task is to prepare a training
data set to train a model which
predicts if a given user will
watch a given movie, then to
achieve this we need two sets
of inputs--
features, that we
have already imported,
and labels, which is the
ground-truth data recorder
that user X has watched
movie Y. It also
includes the time stamp which
indicates when the ground-truth
was actually observed.
As labels and feature values
are collected over time,
those feature values change.
The Feature Store can perform
a point in time lookup
so that you can
fetch the feature
values at a particular time.
It's literally the data
version of going back
to a previous version of
your source code in GitHub.
Imagine freezing the
state of the feature
values at two
different timestamps.
And that was a quick summary
of Vertex Feature Store.
Just know that at the
time of this recording,
the Feature Store is in
preview, so chances there
are more options and
features available when
you're watching this video.
To explore more
up-to-date information,
check out the documentation
that I've linked below.
Any questions, let me
know in the comments
or on Twitter @pvergadia.